for decades space food has been mostly
slurry in a tube but last year
astronauts aboard the ISS enjoyed the
first space salad grown 200 miles from
Earth it was one small leaf for man but
making the giant step 20 g agriculture
was pretty tricky watering alone is a
feat since it wants to float around
bubbles so engineers have devised a
system that carries moisture directly to
the plants roots basically a space chia
pet didja to tia astronauts even grew a
nice bouquet of zinnias hmmm they really
do tie the station together keeping
enough water around is also a challenge
right now there's a pretty ingenious
system that transforms p into usable
water here on board ISS we turn
yesterday's coffee into tomorrow's
coffee but it can break down yes
if humans are going to travel to other
planets will need a better water
recycler so NASA is taking inspiration
from the human gut and working on a
water filter using genetically modified
bacteria to clean up the h2o refresh
you